this is dribbles 1000 plus um little
different from the other ones say the
least
Oh in this one he's like oh hello we see
a little I guess of his backstory when
he was like you know a little baby and
he has a sister as well and they he's
just showing off his ship and he kills
the bride at this wedding they chase him
down and he's looking at these other
grapples just to find a way out and they
let out some interesting answers about
the future yes not doing so um and he
just looks at all these little stories
to find ways to help himself out and at
the very end he fights back and destroys
this poor wedding party uh you know both
the bride and groom are dead several
those guards or friends are dead um and
he gets back to his ship that's mostly
destroyed and tells his sister they
loves her and she goes speech um and
yeah and that's about it so it's it's
funny cuz on the one hand it's like
there's not much to talk about because
you know it's just focus on this guy by
the other hand there's a lot cuz we're
constantly seeing the future in this um
you know but not necessarily any of the
characters only one weekend and I even
then we do kind of see Ice King he's
like this big bearded flying thing
apparently like the crown in him have
just melded more together um we assume
Marceline is still alive because there's
that how I said it seems to be well
capped I mean you know it you saw
everything else they're like rusted over
things grow on it and stuff um so it was
interesting it's I don't know I like
these episodes where you see far into
the past or far into the future and you
wonder how these things connect together
there's always kab like this intriguing
oh but there's also this sample yes it's
like a lot of these people must be dead
now and stuff or maybe not who knows um
you know change I don't like change uh
but no I really like that stuff I like
it
that kind of do that and I I'm glad they
kept it kind of minimal what they show
like you know you see
Marceline's house and I'm thinking to
myself I almost it'd be cool like they
didn't show her it I didn't show like
what you look like in the future and
they don't they keep it a secret but you
know she has to be in there because you
know it'd be destroyed or falling apart
or something she can hear music coming
from inside oh yeah there's that -
exactly so I like that I thought that
was pretty cool um always love emo
Philips uh you know when I first heard
his voice which is probably like UHF
yeah I just didn't know what to think of
it I thought was so odd and now it just
it just tickles me every time I hear it
especially the way he ends his sentences
with the hard liquor my speech you know
like just those hard endings I think are
just so funny um and uh is about it I
liked it it was cool I like these were
you see the future and you can't wonder
how did they get to this point I love
that poor creature that had the tooth in
his ear oh no you know what
god that's we're talking about that she
has their teeth capped and this guy
figures it out and he's trying to get
away and he's trying to start he's
trying to take the tooth out and point
another creature and stuff I'm just like
man yeah I forgot all the questions I
have for bubblegum just like yeah that's
right oh maybe if she's just watching on
the computer like she knows like their
number like she doesn't even be like the
name she just knows by the number I
wonder what star cheese doing like you
know who that is um it just makes her
like all the more fascinating and creepy
at the same time um I see her more she
protective mother uh but was it well I
mean it does kind of make me think as
like starchy is like evolving beyond us
and he's like taking the tooth out okay
he's not super smart still cuz he's not
finding the brightest ways to get rid of
it but it's like it's enough that he
knows to put on this illusion and looks
like it kind of work as the
- stayed in there thousands of years or
however long it was um so I don't know
when you get to that point I'd almost be
like she should we sit down with him and
just feel you know you you've reached
that point no no - for you see the way I
look at it is
they've already fully established these
people are idiots
yeah and I like it's like having a cat
or a dog you get them chipped so if they
something does happen and they do
disappear you can maybe find them I mean
I know I look at it yeah I do I was
thinking of that too uh but they you
know they play up kind of the creep
value of that - that it's like it's
protective but you know this episodes
about how far does her protection go you
know I can with Flame Princess goes to
pest yeah you know I think that's one of
those things where it's like they're
certainly playing with how much of this
is right and how much of it is not which
is good i'm glad they play around that
especially with a character who is
supposed to be a likable main character
uh you know i think that again doesn't
always show oh well this person does it
bad i mean it can happen to a perfectly
nice sensible intelligent person uh you
know so it's it's still fun it is still
like a little creepy
secretly it's the whole uh well i don't
want to call him a bubblegum got a
guardian uh uh the giant yeah candy
machine if you will if you notice she
took that good of care of them that they
lasted years later yeah later they're
still actually being protected well and
they changed a little bit like cuz of
what they originally round or whatever
or on it but i'm not talking the
guardians cuz in the Guardian was each
of those individual one was a candy
person ah that's what i'm saying she
took that good care and cared that much
for each of those candy people then
thousand years in the future they're all
still alive and being protected and
watched over well even that where did
the guardians look a little a little
completely okay i was gonna say i do
remember them looking different I was
just like the future version of it yeah
I never talked about the little things
inside those are actually the candy
people yeah yeah which I think that
shows to me more like yeah she's pretty
creepy and weird
in the end if she actually truly does
care for them to the point where a
thousand years in the future they can
pop out of these things and they're
perfectly fine it does make me wonder
though to you know because if we're
assuming this is a thousand years in
future because it's called thousand
points um all that much stuff has grown
over and yeah um but like Marceline has
never moved a thousand years number one
I know she moved that one time you know
it's how they found her and then she
moved back maybe that's just happened a
couple times she keeps moving away and
then moving back did I say that when she
first made the appearance she's like
this is the treehouse was her home she's
like yeah I just decided to move away
and then they found the other place and
she's like yeah this is my place to I
move around a lot mmm yeah she's always
all over that's like always the place
that she comes back it seems to yeah hmm
um so I mean I thought was my I thought
was fun that setup I mean just what a
fun set up destroying that wedding
having him be chased down and that is
how we get to see these scribbles I mean
I think that's very funny
I just love the whole cracking of the
dome and all since she's like yeah I'm
flipping around up ya know and even the
groom just sort of lit some up eyes legs
and flips them over ah no I thought that
was very very funny
uh but what are your thoughts although
uh same thing I mean I loved
Ice King though like because they it's
kind of I don't want to give anything
away with upcoming episodes but failure
is something that like I don't know how
do I put it properly like I don't know
cuz I haven't seen it either failure is
acceptable and failures eminent mmm Ice
King will forever be trapped like this
no matter what and it's kind of sad in
upcoming episodes what is going on let
me put it that way
for me at least I look at it that way
it's like all well no even seeing that I
mean you like I said just a little bit I
saw I could put some of it together
because it wasn't like here's this
bearded flying creature with the crown
that's like the crown in him have like
fused together
any ass young yeah and that's one of
those things where it's kind of like OTE
haha but it's also like oh well like
self or yeah like now it's just like not
only is he not getting better it's like
getting worse and worse
yeah and a thousand years later I mean
it's just like this yeah he just looks
like one of those demons from those
other episodes yeah um so yeah I mean
there is definitely serve like this
tragedy to it I mean he's always a
tragic character but just like but again
that's why I like these future episodes
when you kind of see how things turn out
it's just kinda like oh but but I like
feeling that too I like feeling like man
that never got resolved that's what a
bummer man just what a bummer you know
but it's like I like feeling that way
for you know a bunch of lines and a
voice you know yeah I just really like
having that connection like that
something can be good enough that it can
make me legitimately feel sorry for that
yeah um for me a lot it's when there's
like a good show you're watching and it
gets cancelled and there's no season for
now lore series finale or anything so
you don't know how the season or series
ends it kind of sucks in a kind of like
whatever but let's say Adventure Time
ends tomorrow it's kind of okay because
we already have stuff that happens way
in the future just like okay you can
kind of almost fill in your own pieces
as it goes along with most shows it's
like in the now in the now and the now
and the now you don't know like what's
going on later on and this one we've
already had at least I can think of
three episodes where we know what
happens in the future I was gonna say
like even like thousands of years in the
past yeah we see what happens so you
kind of like a whole lot which I like I
think that's really cool but but it
still leaves like just just enough
mystery where it's like be still want
know kind of these details like you
could I'm sure people have like piece
together a timeline of what's happened
and what we know and can probably even
connect certain dots that the common
viewer couldn't yeah but even doing that
you know there's still stuff that's like
they're gonna drop even more details
that way I didn't know that now I gotta
add that to the timeline what's going on
and I like that I like that like you
said it's not like you know something
like lost or even even I love the show
and gravity falls were you know
everything is trying to solve the
mystery like you said of the now yeah
it's very much you know just hey here's
kind of just what this world is in many
respects when I could give you
everything or may we will you know just
slowly but surely uh but you get kind of
a very broad scale idea of what this
world is how it is yeah even if you
don't know all the details most shows
will give you present and past episodes
like a lot of times you'll see in a show
like so go here's the characters oh look
at this is what the character was like
when they were younger or hey a lot is
the whole time-travel ones where it's
like let's see how the parent character
was when they were kid you know or let's
look in the future in the future is
always it because they do it a couple
times like five different futures that
don't connectors yeah so I like that
they don't it seems like they don't go
into the future too much on this show
they don't dwell on it yeah they give
you more than enough and most shows
don't even give you future episodes
let's stick with the now or the past and
that's about it
and this one we've already seen the Finn
and Jake's tree like you've seen at
least it's really really tall and then
there's this one you know with lemonhope
and all that stuff so for me it's like I
like seeing you can fill in the blanks
if you wish or you can leave it how it
is but you know that Finn and Jake will
no longer exist you know that bubblegum
will no longer like you know that this
is not this infinite timeline that will
never end there is an end
characters will die things will end you
know which is nice it gives it a
morality which makes you at least me
connect with the characters more well
than the ones that don't again it's like
forming a very different connection yeah
again to captors are still around Ice
King and Marceline and you know we don't
see Marceline which again I really like
especially after they show us the ice
yeah uh and but we assume she's doing
okay because she's in this house she's
playing her guitar whatever I mean we
don't know much outside that but we know
she's not like you know hiding in a
ditch or just like oh man whatever I
mean it's like she she seems to be okay
she's in her house and playing the
guitar yeah you know with the Ice King I
mean you know things have gotten worse
and I just love that contrast that's
like
they do show you kind of what's happened
with two characters but you know not a
ton just enough for you to go huh you
know like you get really really
intrigued like how did get to that point
beacon also very much guess how it got
to that point or how these things uh
either stay the way they were got to
where they were it's like driving down
the street at night and you're looking
at everyone's houses you're driving by
you just get that I want to kill second
that's what happens when I Drive I mean
I mean uh no you get this what second
just tiny little peek into everyone's
lives most of all only empty you won't
see anything sometimes you'll catch this
a little glimpse like Marceline you only
hear what's going on there you don't see
anything
I ski quick seat you know and that's
kind of what it is it's like you're just
getting tiny little snapshots you know
and you can't really gather what's going
on but you can guess yeah you know no I
definitely liked it it's funny cuz like
the actual stories themselves we didn't
talk that much about but it's like
they're just sort of like here's some
goofy things teehee haaa and then here's
like these incredible like glimpses into
the future of these characters that you
know you've no fur God knows I'm a
episodes um but like a brick he had a
brick ice King's with his broken leg
another broken leg oh I'll try to cut
that together I'm like so okay there
there's a brick he just tries to brick
okay it's only weird now I got that's
how he broke the leg or I actually took
Moore's misery liya like put it between
us yeah but I only get to one leg yeah
we made a kill a limp a sledge hammer
once um but I liked it I thought it was
fun
ya know I liked it too I like said those
little glimpses I think are really
really cool yeah so yeah this will be
the last time you see us in these
clothes uh thank because next time we're
gonna be butt naked I'll still have my
hat but but naked don't say that cuz you
know I'll do that I have no shame
but close so it's just my butt closed
but nothing else
damn it